we got this story from the hill holly
blackburn called for biden to resign
there's been other insinuations that he
should be impeached if he's not if he
doesn't resign but then what do we do do
we do president kamala yeah yeah please
anything is better than this guy right
now it's military we he left thousands
of people behind that's right
and they were and they said they didn't
want a black hawk down moment they
didn't want to send in this is like the
iranian hostage thing which was the big
it was a 52 people 52 and already 13
people have been killed times times a
hundred like people didn't die no one
died in that that scandal that hostage
scandal that i know of they were rescued
these people died already right i sound
like jimmy dore jimmy i love you these
are these are us troops who were there
knowing the risks or they were they were
officially affiliated with the troops
they weren't all troops right they were
military there are 13 dead u.s service
members servicemen on top no they're
marines and a navy medic corpsman and
then they're also civilian casualties
although i don't think we have the
numbers on the civilian casualties yet
bunch of afghani or
afghani by the way is the currency i
know people keep saying that when they
try to say the plural right afghan
plenty of civilian afghans i believe
died in the imagine uh serving on a ship
with a captain who's you know
let's just call let's let's call them
sporadic
and you're like i'm here to do my duty
and then the people who are on shore are
like hey we're going to put this crazy
old man up in there
i i can't i can't imagine what it must
feel like for a lot of these guys who
are like i'm going to do my best but
they know deep down they're in trouble
because if bidens can control your ship
he fires at the enemy ship and he misses
and he
thinks about how to do it again he's got
people and then your ship gets hit with
the with the
artillery round and then all of a sudden
everyone realizes they're going to die
and that's what people don't understand
can happen in reality if you're lazy
with military they didn't think about
any of this
when look joe biden campaigned to be
president he said i want that job he
knew trump negotiated this deal to
withdraw biden said i want to be in
charge of the world's most powerful
military and a bunch of people said i
would like that man to have control of
the world's most powerful military and
to oversee our withdrawal from
afghanistan and the middle east
and this is what they voted for he's
been running for president since the
late 1980s yeah he's been plagiarizing
this by the way i mean him being
president the way he is is like you ever
see that old twilight zone episode where
the guy is finally alone to read all the
books he wants but he breaks his glasses
you spend your entire life
most of your entire life you spend a lot
of your life trying to be president and
you finally get it and it turns out you
are too incompetent to even execute the
basic duties of your office it was time
now it was my time it's not fair
this is not fair oh my god man you know
i'm a president here's the deal but so
like to your point if it's just sheer
incompetence maybe kamala could could
take up but that's
he's not going to get impeached he's not
going to resign unless he's not fit for
command though you've got to relieve him
of command i think you'll have 25
minutes you'll have to drag him from the
oval office with his teeth markings
25th amendment kamala harris what if she
comes out because 25th amendment
requires the vice president to come out
and say the president is not competent
and then pelosi set up that panel they
were expecting this
i don't know look i you were saying
earlier that no behind the curtain comm
was like that is my time
i don't know have you seen her recently
in some of her public appearances she's
got a i don't want to be here right
she's shaken i mean not just shaking but
like she sees what's happening and you
think she wants to be in charge of this
the cleanup after this would you want it
i wouldn't want it i wouldn't do it but
i
that's what i'm saying is she going to
you know work behind the scenes to take
this and i want to clean this up here's
here's the difference
you ian you and kamala both don't want
it you don't want it because you don't
want to be in charge you don't want to
control have the power but you're
willing to accept responsibility to do
the right thing to fix the mess kamala
doesn't want it because she doesn't want
to deal with the mess she just wants the
power you see how that works
do you want the title
commonly called the
doesn't want to deal with the crisis she
just wants the power then she's not fit
for command either exactly but we keep
saying not fit for command it extends
beyond biden maybe biden is an f up who
doesn't understand foreign policy as
he's shown for the last several decades
but the generals this is literally their
job is knowing this stuff who signed off
on all this who okayed it who didn't
push back i mean millie didn't push back
do it miller can't be the only one who
else
how many the head does there need to be
a
they were too busy dealing with white
rage you know i want to understand you
want to hear about white rage i got some
white rage right now over this yeah
write general milly about this
it's i don't know where it goes from
here i don't know doesn't end well who's
responsible for this who makes the call
of where the money goes ron paul
he's such a such a funny character he's
the one you know he's one of those guys
that
before
you know when i first started covering
politics i was like this seems like a
goofy little man
and then
repeatedly was like oh he was right
about that yeah and we like and be like
well i didn't i didn't doubt him i'm
like oh i did i mean the one the one big
one i'm sorry i know this is a total
tangent was out of the fed and i was
like this is silly and then the fed's
like you absolutely will not out at us
i'm like okay
why not yeah okay now you've seen casino
remember when sharon stone asks her
husband robert de niro for money because
she wants to go see her pimp boyfriend
and she doesn't want to tell her husband
that but she asked for like fifteen
thousand dollars and he's like what for
and then she makes a big stink she's
like i shouldn't have to tell you what
he's like and then the line and i'm
always reminded with this stuff he's
like well i wasn't i wasn't interested
but now i am yeah that's how i feel with
a lot of stuff that ron paul talked
about like i didn't really have a strong
opinion on this but the fact that you
guys are so reluctant to do this now
i got to be honest you know
i'd take a president ian right now
i'd take a president tim
for sure yeah i don't want to be
president but i want to be military
strategy that's just the top of the game
right i just want to be vice president
just travel the world shake hands try
new food be great we'd be we'd be better
off with like
you know uh rick smith from dubuque iowa
who's like a local plumber as president
it's the old buckley's saying is that
you'd be better off being ruled by three
random names from the phone book than
most of these eggheads and that's right
people can you think you can do this
better i'm like yes me and three
completely random people could probably
do what's happening in afghanistan
better i know enough that you'd get the
civilians out first like this isn't hard
not only that but uh some of the the
low-ranking guys in afghanistan could
have done a better job and i imagine
that's gonna be really frustrating to be
deployed on the ground knowing and
sitting there being like why are they
doing this they're understaffed and
they're under resourced over there
they're working with what they have
which is not great and the other thing
too i don't think a lot of people have
been talking about this sort of
psychological angle to this the guys who
are there now know that they're working
on the final chapter to a big foreign
policy failure they know everything
they're doing has been a build up to
failure and they've been tasked now with
trying to get the last americans out
while surrounded by the taliban can you
imagine what that job is even like and
then losing at least 13 of your
colleagues all in the same day i mean
this is none of this had to happen you
know i i this was all
uh this was all done by a president in a
white house that doesn't know what it's
doing or
some people have suggested it's actually
just malicious
i've had those jobs man where you're
like my boss is dumb and they don't know
how this stuff works there's a lot of
jobs you'll get where the manager is
hired externally and so they've never
actually worked say the uh the soda
machine or the cash register and they're
sitting there trying to tell you how it
works and you're like dude you have no
idea what you're talking about right
it's frustrating i could not imagine
what it must be like to be deployed in
afghanistan and knowing what's going on
in the country knowing how the people
react knowing what the taliban is and
then getting these orders where you're
like you want me to do what right
because this is your life on the line
this ain't a cheeseburger or a cash
register i can't imagine what the u.s
marines feel like seeing
afghans possible afghan allies uk
nationals people with their papers and
they can't take them or go out and
defend them because they've been ordered
to stay put the 82nd airborne has been
ordered not to go outside of kabul to
save americans and other people while
the british paratroopers are going in
and the french special forces have been
going under these sort of daring night
raids all over and the americans just
have to sit there i can't imagine how
demoralizing how uh much of a shock that
must be this like as an american like
look at civilians
we know the idea that americans being
left behind is is such a this is i never
thought that this could happen i can't
imagine what this is like for guys
dedicated his life to being in the armed
services would it be like to you can't
go out and get those americans i can't
do that and we might leave some behind
that that's gotta you know they talk a
lot during the trump year sorry not to
interrupt i talked a lot during the
trump years about unprecedented stuff
the idea that we are uncoursed to
abandon americans in a foreign country
to a terrorist death cult
nothing like that has happened in this
country before you know what really
tears at me
i mean obviously the u.s troops and the
loss of life is the biggest thing but
i'm just thinking like
if they didn't abandon the afghan
security forces the way they did
afghanistan could have been successful
it could have been
they could in fact you know uh we've
talked with other uh vets on the show
where they said something like you draw
down you know the overall majority 90
plus percent of american forces leave a
few commanders or you know strategy
logistics with some air support some
drones and it's it's done we we get out
that minimal support can help keep
things secure and then i look at what
happened with with evacuating the air
force bases in the middle of the night
not informing the afghan uh security
forces and i'm i i wonder if
if biden did this properly would there
be a secure afghanistan right now for
their people
i mean maybe a big problem that the u.s
military has also reported is that the
afghan
government is extremely corrupt and
susceptible to bribes and looking at
their way another problem that i know a
lot of military have reported is that
the afghans that they've tried to train
the training has been very difficult
because there's a lot of lack of
discipline
um
i've seen the videos man can't do
jumping jacks stuff like that it's
called side saddle uh people jumping
jacks people straight up abandoning yeah
just walking away because they don't
want it
because they don't want to do it anymore
so i don't know if afghan
sorry if afghanistan would still be
standing with just a few things
different i mean it's not like for
it's not like there was a lack of
spending or a lack of arms or lack of
training so maybe it would stan maybe
would fall but when they keep the white
house keep saying we plan for all
contingencies apparently afghanistan
falling to the taliban was not one of
those contingencies and how you
overlooked that despite everything you
were being told by your guys on the
ground about how difficult it is to
train them and how
corrupt the government is well known
corrupt everyone knew that
we all know that we don't work in
government we don't work in the united
states military we know it's corrupt
it's interesting i always wondered like
what
why is bribery so less common here you
know
i don't think it is no no no it is it's
bribery is common but it's much less
common like
i i hear these stories oh look when you
get pulled over
would you say to the officer how much to
no i say may the ticket go away of
course not never going to happen not the
europeans but in russia in russia and
south america too in peru i was going to
say costa rica i was in costa rica once
i was warned that cops will try to shake
you down for a
for a bribe so okay yeah to that point
that's what you mean it's it's
substantially more common in so many
other countries and i wonder why that is
uh maybe we have more watch dogs more
robust
scruples like rule of law fear like i
can't do that that's just wrong or i
could get in trouble
you know we we know the cops gonna
arrest you for it there's most likely
yeah yeah but in these other countries
the cops expect it
i don't know i mean i think maybe just a
lack of of robust law system lack of uh
respect for law i'm not trying to get
all you know blue lives matter or
whatever but like this is a very sort of
strong culture in america you know you
you pull over your respect
you have that interaction i've never
once been tempted to slide a cop a 50
bill or anything yeah it's weird i think
that would end very poorly for me yeah
yeah that would probably just be like
i would imagine it's a felony right yeah
yeah you can bribe a cop i i believe
rule of law man that's a big big part of
the foundation of this this whole
project of the united states it's it's
sad when people
do things that especially people in
power do things that are illegal and and
don't get reprimanded for it you like
the president's son
yeah and like hillary clinton with
emails like that was viciously illegal
what she did because she skirted all
foia laws i'm not all into like
punishing everyone for every crime all
the time like i definitely like leniency
and like these people on january 6th
should be released that should all be
pardoned that's
we need unity right now
um
but i mean at some point you've got to
this is law and order you you know why
you get january 6 because of hillary
clinton getting away yes yes
i mean i don't
i don't know if the two are generally
generally connected but i will say one
thing that's really demoralizing and it
easy to give into anger is the
expectation that people like hunter and
hillary will never see justice and they
break laws that anyone else would go
away well this is what i mean when
people feel demoralized like there's
nothing they can do to actually
get justice we're living under anarcho
tyranny they just they
what do you what do you what do you do
when you back an animal into a corner
it's gonna fight you get a rabbit
rabbits like to run right but you put it
into a you know one dimensional uh a
borough for instance they have no they
have nowhere to go they fight
and so that's why when people get
desperate they do desperate things going
back to our earlier conversation about
desperation
that's why i i i agree with you on the
pardoning of these people outright
because as much as people might not want
to do it it you need to be like okay
we're gonna we're gonna call time out on
this one we're gonna say guys
please don't do this
we're gonna let these guys go
john hancock did that after shae's
rebellion we've talked a little bit
about it right after the articles of
confederation were signed big you know i
don't know if you know much about the
farmers rebellion that caused them
basically they had to centralize command
of taxes because the states were taxing
the farmers the farmers didn't have the
money to pay so they revolted
uh john hancock pardoned those guys i
think two people ended up getting put to
death for the rebellion but he pardoned
like everybody that was involved
and i know because of that we have a
country today if he persecuted those
people we probably wouldn't have thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time